[موسيقى]
كان لدينا بالفعل متجرنا الوحدة و6-2
أوه
[موسيقى]
أمي أمي أمي أمي الحذاء الرياضي والليمون
والعمليات الجراحية تصيبني نقابة تيلام
من دوني
وسيم فيتنام والظل
نشيط
شرق سرت لا سمارت
- اليوم هو قياس فران اليوم هذا والدي
أمي أبي أمي الحياة بلدي الليمون البالغ من العمر ست سنوات و
العمليات الجراحية لم تذهب للذخيرة
من دوني
اليوم يعود لي اليوم سيكون اليوم
سيئة للعيش في أمريكا اللاتينية
lanny ل
أمي أمي أبي أمي الحياة ولا 61 ليمون و
العمليات الجراحية لا توقف العالم هناك 11
في روحي
لم يضطر أبدًا إلى التوقيع عليه ، فسيكونون مستعدين لذلك
من التفكير
انظر إلى هذا منذ أن أخبرت
السائقين
lanny ل
أبي أمي أبي أمي الحياة ولا 61 الليمون و
لا توقفني العمليات الجراحية عند العوامة الأحادية
امامي
لا شيء يعود إلى العد سبعة
أشهر قبل أن أعمل العديد من أشكال
معاملة الماء يساوي أبدا
[موسيقى]